Jason you and Jalen have obviously been
through here all together since day one
how important is it this team to keep
them here long term is he goes into
extension talks this summer
oh that's extremely important you know
he's one of the best players in this
league
please
both ends of the ball and
you know still relatively young so
and he's accomplished a lot so far in
his career
saw things extremely extremely important
Jason how would you with that said uh
how did you look at Joe who had a you
know tough start obviously thrown into
that position as the interim and then
you guys grew as a team how would you
look at what job was able to do with you
guys all season and as you went along
grow with him
I mean this is first year we got to the
Conference Finals game seven
um
I don't think people give him less
enough credit that
two days before the season start you
know find out we don't have a new coach
we didn't have Rob the first 25 30 games
of the season
we never got a chance to have gallo and
we got a new coach
one day before immediate day
you know as was an adjustment
we uh we all figured it out
obviously
if we want to win a championship didn't
happen but you know I think Joe did a
great job
and we won 50 some odd games we got
to game seven Conference Finals
obviously everybody can be better learn
from this
but you know I think Joe did a great job
this year